so scrolls are the bad guys  and you're free  a race of noble lawyers heroes noble  warrior heroes  [Music]  your life began the day it nearly ended  we found you with no memory we made you  one of us so you could live longer  stronger superior  you were reborn  I keep having these  memories something in my past is the key  to all of this  you're not a flatus thing you see that's  a yes or no question yes  [Music]  would you like to know  what you really are  I think I had a life here  what aren't you telling me  you've come a long way the universe  strong as you think  the slaw is just the beginning  I'm not going to fight your war  [Music]  I'm gonna end it  [Music]  I'm super cute as lovely aren't you  what's your name Jerry's hmm